Speaker 1: This is one of the strangest clips from
right wing media from the reaction to the Derek
Chauvin verdict. Tucker Carlson had an apparent
psychotic break during a segment last night with
a former New York City corrections officer during
which Tucker started maniacally laughing in a way
that was reminiscent of Jack Nicholson's joker
from the Batman movie and then abruptly ended the
segment and kicked the guest off of his show. And
much of what Tucker does on his program in general
appears to be acting. And Fox News lawyers have
even said Tucker does entertainment. He's not
like literal news. But something about this
segment strikes me as the real Tucker Tucker
seemingly unhinged. Let's take a look at
the clip Tucker is interviewing at Gavyn,
former New York City corrections officer.
The former corrections officer said, listen,
Derek Shervin used excessive force on George
Floyd. Tucker Carlson just loses it. Look at this
Speaker 2: scene. I just think that it was
excessive and what should happen and what
I'd like to see why you did it looks like he's
going to spend the rest of his life in prison. So
I'm kind of more worried about the rest of the
country, which, thanks to police and action,
in case you haven't noticed, is like
boarded up. So that's more like.
Sure. Come on. Ed Gavin, thank you. Now done.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Isn't that something if you
thought that the Matt Gates interview was weird
two, three weeks ago because of Gates's behavior,
it was nothing compared to Tucker's behavior
last night. What do you think this is
about? Like is it is this that Tucker maybe
senses that the showband verdict is part of
their grip slipping away and maybe a new era of
accountability being ushered in? That would be
great. I don't think that's actually why Tucker
is behaving like this. Was Tucker planning on
running video of violent riots from Minnesota
last night and there were no violent riots.
So this is what he came up with. Instead, one
cop found guilty and Tucker is instantly off
his rocker. It's very weird. And the laugh is
particularly unsettling, but also kicking the
guest off when you supposedly run a show that's
about discussing ideas, even when your ideas
might conflict with somebody else's, it's bad
enough. And of course, this gets us back to the
really consequential piece of all of this, which
is that there are so many people who watch Tucker
and they take him seriously and they take his show
seriously and they take his perspective seriously.
You and I might see this and say, first of all,
how can anyone watch this and react by saying,
wow, this seems like a good place to take
my my opinions from. But there are people
who will react and not think that that's a
completely unhinged person. And for many people,
sadly, shows like Tucker Carlson's are the only
input that they receive. To form their view
of what's going on in the world and in the
United States, and that's a really scary thing.
Now one one other note. This isn't the only
time that Tucker has sort of broken like this.
There was that incident. It feels like it
was maybe a year and a half to two years ago
when Dutch historian Rutger Bregman, who's
been a guest on this show, you can check out
my interview with Rutger on our YouTube channel.
Rutger Bregman was interviewed by Tucker.
Tucker didn't like the direction the
interview was going. Rutger was clearly
not laying down for Tucker Carlson. Tucker went
nuts attacking Rutger Bregman, swearing at him,
and then refused to air the interview. We
only found out about it because fortunately,
there was a recording that was released.
So we were able to see it. But between that
and Tucker's reportedly losing it at his own
country club on an employee or some other guest,
you can look that story up. My sense is
that the 20 seconds I played for you here
of Tucker, both furious with his guest and
laughing maniacally in a way that seems completely
divorced from from reality. That, I believe is
the real Tucker that I think is the closest we
get to the real Tucker, because it matches the
tucker that we saw in what Tucker hoped would
be an unaired interview with Rutger Bregman.
And it's the same Tucker that is described
in his country club outburst. I think that's
the real Tucker. Let me know what you think.